the new edition of the Kalina is
intended to give Russian car maker Lada
a foothold in the European stationwagon
segment and on the price front it's
certainly making an impact among its
direct rivals is the Fabia combi in
Germany the Skoda sells for prices
starting at just over 13,000 euros dachi
as Logan MCV is considerably cheaper the
basic version costs just under 8,000
euros but they're both undercut by the
Kalina the entry-level model costs seven
thousand seven hundred fifty euros in
Germany but just how much car can you
expect for that price tag people have
certain basic requirements explains our
car man on today number one is no not
driving it's drinking but when you get
to the store is regular water enough or
should he get a trendy isotonic drink
well Andre faces a similar question with
this test car the Lada Kalina basically
it has everything you need for mobility
but you might regret buying one later
because you actually wanted a little
more the design might not be to the
tastes of drivers who like their car to
be on the fashionable side either but
there's certainly no shame in owning a
Kalina plus it's just the right height
for easy access the interior however is
a bit like a trip back in time the
reduced design and the display elements
in the dashboard are so 1990s
the truck has sufficient cargo space
while the cupholders and stowage spaces
and the doors will likewise cover
requirements the designers weren't so
creative when it came to the interior
reckons Andre there's hard plastic
everywhere what he does like are the
knobs here which are easy to operate
that sensation Medina's edema control
must hear what he really doesn't like is
the parking brake for starters it
doesn't look too slick and when he
pushes it down it doesn't snap into
place
Andre finds it irritating only star
struck me Jennifer
the Kalima is powered by a 1.6 liter 4
cylinder engine with outputs of 64 or 72
kilowatts we checked out the latter
version which in Germany sells for nine
thousand six hundred ninety euros
so the Lada Kalina felt a bit like
driving a used car built in 2000 you do
have power steering and power windows
but the noise inside is rather
overbearing more than normal yeah
it was pendants huntsmen hurt mia its
back on all trolls to Charlotte all the
gear shifts are a little slack Andre
does have a highlight the seat heating
which gets a very warm very fast
he's inside someone you gots Ned auntie
mom and the best thing about the seat
heating it's part of the standard
equipment the outside the Kalina seems a
little tall and that's confirmed in the
handling the car tends to sway and it's
not exactly on the sporty side and for
German roads the suspension travel is
perhaps a little excessive but if you're
on rougher roads or a forest path he'll
be okay with the Kalina done thanks is
momentum Cuddy not seen News Corp it
Dean's summing up the Kalina has
standard fitted power windows seat
heating and other features which you
wouldn't expect for the price but in
other areas you immediately see where
Lada cut costs that said the Kalina is
certainly worth considering for thrifty
car buyers
so basically says Andrei the Lada Kalina
has everything to cover your basic
mobility needs although he personally
would want a little more